to present the award for the best motion
picture of the year the distinguished
producer of last year's Best Picture mr.
buddy Adam
good evening that was more nervous last
year but I'm just as excited this year
last year on the waterfront
I'm very grateful to all of you in this
year of great achievements in the motion
picture industry all of us who worked on
waterfront are deeply appreciative to
all of you for the honor for the
compliment and for the distinction thank
you very much well ladies and gentlemen
there you are it's all over but the
sniveling I hope all your favorites won
of course you and I know that one of
them didn't that's the price you pay
when you refused to go commercial the
show is over the party's is just
beginning some of the winners would go
to
Romanovs some will go to chastens and if
you're listening in down at Stan's
drive-in one weirder than coffee
that's been a very wonderful night the
rewards were divided up I think very
wonderfully with New York and LA your
show to that of course was sponsored by
Oldsmobile remember if you want a
champagne car on a beer budget stay off
the highway you're in no condition to
drive and in conclusion the management
has asked me to summarize the meaning of
this entire spectacle get an Oldsmobile
and ride to the movies
the Academy Award has been brought to
you by your Oldsmobile dealer who invite
you to see max liebman's production of
The Merry Widow over NBC television
Saturday evening April 9th